Disney announced on Wednesday that they
will be rebooting ducktales starting in
2017 I'm super excited about this and
I'm surprised you're here Dave because I
thought you were too cool for cartoons
what no way I'm a total duck head
oh what a duck head I thought you said
Jim welcome to hash tag news I'm JB
Paquito and I'm Dave hole writer and
with this big news everyone has a bunch
of big question scores the first one
being which of our favorite characters
are returning for the reboot first we
have to clarify what you mean by
characters you know because there
actually is a huge Kentucky universe oh
I know that okay obviously you've got
Huey Dewey and Louie who after their dad
died in a firework explosion and their
mom went to space that's a true fact by
the way look it up there uncle Donald
who took care of them until he got
trapped in the Navy to go fight in Korea
also a true fact but then they were
given up to their great idol Scrooge
McDuck
a ripoff of Scrooge Nick evany sir but
it doesn't stop there right obviously
everybody knows that their uncle Donald
is friends with goofy which means his
entire goof troop world as part of the
stuff universe yeah sure but did you
know that they also are connected
through the Disney comic legend of the
Kaos God to the TaleSpin world and all
those weird characters yeah I totally
knew that but did you know that they're
also connected through the same comic to
the Chippendales Rescue Rangers that no
that can't be because they have humans
in their show and the animal characters
hide their ability to talk in from them
I know but I propose that Chip and Dale
all are is actually set in an ancient
prehistoric time similar to now where
humans and animals shared the earth and
animals simply hid their intelligence
from the humans and minded their own
business then there was some sort of
extinction level of it and yeah yes and
it wiped out all of mankind that caused
animals to take over the earth and
establish civilizations that wear
clothes I got pants no because they
didn't want to make the same mistakes
like humans did
so you're basically describing a Planet
of the Apes type scenario with cartoon
ducks and whatever goofy is as the Apes
and humans as humans exactly so which
characters are coming back please
wait wait wait I didn't see his mom duck
we know times are really differ
now than they were in the feel-good late
80s Early 90s it's not so cool to rub
your wealth in everyone's face will
ducktales still show off Scourge McDuck
as king of the 1% like you might not
actually want a rich guy literally
swimming through a pool of his gold coin
speak for yourself
they'd better it's easily one of the
best Disney animated theme songs of all
time right above the chip to chip & Dale
Rescue Rangers theme song and right
below eye to eye from the goofy so is
the theme song coming back well Disney
wouldn't tell us but what we're really
nervous about is if they update it to
something that kids are listening to
these days
hit it life is like a hurricane here and
I forgot fur racecars lazers
airplanes it's a duck blur blur Mike
cell phone picture we are we write
history duck tales
this is horrible
please do not do that for the new thing
it's okay I don't think anyone would
ever use that for anything it wasn't
that bad you didn't see it it was bad
weren't you just decapitated that's it
for hashtag news oh my god gave they
made it to the end of the video it's not
incredible
this is a first whoa if you like us that
much we go ahead and subscribe to our
Channel I mean we're all fed up on the
news net you don't have to be yeah I got
makes what we do worthwhile if you like
geeking out with us also then you know
we can like this video too there's a
button somewhere on the screen that will
do that share it with your duck head
friends and share in our enthusiasm
what were you very much so and leave
your enthusiastic comments right below
tell us what duck tales character that
you're most excited to see comeback or
honestly any other shows that you want
to see comeback I go back to my gold
bass